après presque quatre années de captivité
le soulagement à la suite de l'annoncé
de sa libération sophie petronet arrivée
à l'aéroport de bamako la nuit dernière
vêtus de blanc et foulard sur la tête la
dernière otage française dans le monde a
immédiatement remercié les autorités
maliennes
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas prêt si jamais on est
presque à 47 dans le lot pour soigner la
dépression etc
heureusement ma plus grande joie
aujourd'hui est de savoir une
monarchiste en a beaucoup aimé être dans
une forme voilà alors pour le mali de
prier et à implorer la démission les
rennais diction et la miséricorde
[Musique]
en décembre 2016 l'humanitaire française
avaient été enlevées par des hommes
armés à gao dans le nord du pays
emmanuel macron s'est félicité de la
nouvelle en évoquant son immense
soulagement et à échanger par téléphone
avec la septuagénaire bordelaise sophie
petrona est libre retenu en otage depuis
près de quatre ans au mali sa libération
est un immense soulagement
à sa famille à ses proches j'adresse un
message de sympathie aux autorités
maliennes
merci le combat contre le terrorisme au
sahel se poursuit trois autres otages
ont été libérés en même temps que sophie
petrona deux italiens mais aussi
soumaïla cissé une figure de
l'opposition malienne
une opération en forme de réussite pour
les nouvelles autorités de bamako